oder ist was sie wissen wir fast an
ich dachte wir müssen kunstaktion
weswegen wie soll ich dich empfangen
[Musik]
heute treffe ich katja kipping
bundestagsmitglied parteivorsitzende der
die linke und befürworterin der
vier-tage-woche herzlich willkommen ich
bin gegen die vier tage woche richtig
vier tagen
vielleicht können sie hat so eine
einkommensgruppe braucht drei tage
reichen würden weil wir es eher so vier
tage kann dass die öffentlich bezahlen
deswegen klar werbeblock wie schon
gezahlt
spielen sie computerspiele ich bin bei
am morgen dann ausgestiegen
ihr seid jetzt schatzsucher auf der
suche nach einem alten artefakt nach dem
schädel aus diamanten
[Musik]
müssen wir denn hier gelandet
das ist eine gute frage hat die vision
ein bisschen romantischer ist dass ihr
sind romantik blitzer einschlagen naja
wir müssen jetzt irgendwie so ein schatz
finden wenn wir weiter gehen kann sehr
sein dass irgendwo hinkommen wo es
dunkel ist auch hier seine fackel und da
muss man der hand drauf legen oder sie
sind aber griffen zum glück brennt jetzt
nichts sondern dass das immer gut wir
haben licht und gehen weiter auch hier
ist ja schön und sie haben das in höhe
langsam gesorgt
das find ich ja höchst ob es ist nicht
das holz wir können einfach drauf jetzt
geht es runter das können sie von ihren
umfrage würden bestimmt nicht senkrecht
steht die sind kurz wieder nach oben
gegangen aber sie sind natürlich in der
tat zu niedrig ja sondern gibt es den
ersten toten also das kann uns auch
passieren wenn jean todt dazu sagen sie
man hat zumindest ein skelett diesen
gedanken sind hier nach wie vor höchst
inspirierend das war ein schön ist hier
wie stehen sie persönlich zuzuwarten
mäusen ratten sind gar nicht das problem
mein problem sind eher hunde hier ist
wieder solo
wie jetzt da will ich mal mehr zu lösen
das ist ja nicht verraten aber
verhinderte vor bellenden hunden das
finde ich schon irgendwie
das ist eine gemeinsamkeit mit angela
merkel also ich finde jetzt auch noch
mehr gemeinsam
ich finde man kann ja deutlich mehr
vorwerfen irgendwas wird jetzt hier
bestimmt passieren und aufgehen aber ich
frage mich gerade was ja ja ja ist schon
die tür weg gehen sie mal durch
kommen sie nicht mit ich würde mal sagen
ich warte mal ich habe vor seiner tür zu
verbreiten sie auf
aber es ist krass oder man denkt
wirklich man unter einem witz tief nach
unten soll runtergefallen
das alte china sie lag dass ich komme
hier nicht weiter solch einen arm
ausstrecken
das geht gegen korona ja nicht dann
müssen sie springen tut mir leid da kann
ich sie soll ich denn da rüber springen
das absolut möglich natürlich ist es
möglich ein ordentlicher spagat sprung
kann sie nicht irgendwie man muss den
machen sehen wir mal vor den spagat
sprung über die entfernung und jetzt
fahren sie auch einfach hoch oder was
ist das soziale frage frau kipping rose
oder abhauen ich hier auf keinen fall ab
wenn sie jetzt irgendwie daran
höhenangst habe setze ich mich hin und
rhede ihnen gut zu war ich habe eine
frage ja dann erst bei der nächsten wahl
die grüne grün rot rote mehrheit gibt
woran der wird die linkskoalition
diesmal scheitern
ich hoffe er dass sie nicht scheitern
wird das ist ja auch eine verpflichtung
ich einfach finde wir brauchen wir
brauchen eine politik wechseln wir
brauchen einen sozial ökologische wende
und die wird mit der cdu nicht kommen
also das sieht man ja haben sie sich
gerade hingelegt
das nicht ich setze mich hin um ihn gut
zuzureden wenn sie das alleine auf der
säule stehen wenn sie jetzt panik
kriegen ist im spiel vorgesehen dass man
irgend ein rettungsseil hat man reden
ich zwölf muss man vielleicht mal
handeln dann gehe ich jetzt weiter ja
sie sind das safe genug handeln es wir
reden nur kratzer also ich würde sagen
sie gehen wir um die ecke und schauen ob
sie nicht irgendwie das mittel für mich
vermessen
ich stehe hier ich habe ja auch hören
sie hier
klatten stück holz und was wir jetzt mal
machen ist ganz tief und ruhig atmen
brocken auf einem
geburtsvorbereitungskurs dran ist wo ich
tief in den bauch einordnung dann
langsam ausatmen uns wird doppel zu
lange und sich immer auch ziel
konzentrieren
12 34 und jetzt wieder tief einatmen 2
über ventilieren 1
wenn die linken der spd vorwurf machen
ist das nicht ein bisschen so als
veganer mit einem vegetarier 5 das
trifft glaube ich auch ein paar
kritikpunkte von uns zu hause zum
beispiel wenn die jetzt sagen oder
mindestlohn soll 12 euro seien und wie
gesagt mehr aber das reicht perspektiv
ich nicht und so weiter da ist es so
stimmt der vergleich es gibt aber noch
ein paar sachen wo wir sagen mensch ihr
habt ja überhaupt nicht das
grundsätzliche problem richtig erkannt
und in angriff genommen
es ist aber schön warm ist das ist das
nicht beeindruckend das ist ja
faszinierend aber es ist kein wirkliches
feuer oder naja wirklich reinpacken
naja was immer es ist es ist heiß ein
knackpunkt zwischen spd und linker ist
ja auch über die nato die linke sagt ja
kurz gesagt nein die spd sagt ja aber
wenn wir jetzt nicht mehr der nato sind
und der russe uns angreift dann haben
wir nur noch gerhard schröders wenn er
zwischen verheerende vorstellung auf den
angewiesen zu sein eben aber das thema
nato das hat sich doch erledigt weil das
ist doch kein werte bündnis mehr also
bitte welche werte verbinden und dann
mit donald trump oder mit erdogan der
jetzt mal die südlichen gebiete wieder
bombardiert hat aber wenn wir nicht mehr
in der nato sind kann es nicht nur der
russe anfragen sondern auch die nato
sehen sie nicht die gefahr
ich glaube er ist ja dass wenn man
frieden und entspannungs politik will
ist viel notwendiger ist auch mit
russland zu reden und das sage ich erst
jemand der sozusagen wahrscheinlich wenn
russland wer dort die protestbewegung
mitunter also dort beim teil der
protestbewegung wer aber sie haben es
wahrscheinlich ganz sicher sind sie sich
nicht ob sie teil der bewegung
das problem ist er bei welcher
protestbewegung handelt ist weil die
sind ja es sind ja ich habe mich mit
leuten von privat getroffen und so
weiter
das sind natürlich interesse also was
ist an der kunstszene an feministischen
initiativen gibt usw
aber wenn überlegung was mit mir dann
passiert wenn man
in russland dort politisch aktiv ist das
war ihr aber ist dann ist da nicht doch
die nato eine gute sache ich finde ich
finde man braucht internationale
zusammenarbeit
aber die muss über die uno laufen die
muss über die
weltgesundheitsorganisation laufen
die muss über das übersehen hatte er das
flüchtlingswerk laufen über die
klimaschutz konferenz der un aber nicht
über die nato und das ziel kann auch
nicht sein wie sozusagen wie stellen wir
uns in einem krieg gegen russland auf
sondern wie ich schon wie sorgen wir für
eine entspannungs politik damit
überhaupt nicht erst ebenso einer
kriegsgefahr punkt okay
apropos entspannung müssen schnell sind
sie schon verspannt oder ist auch eine
schöne starten aber ist hier was muss
man da irgendetwas drücken machen ich
glaube nicht so ein bisschen wie gysi
sieht wütende aus macht aber nichts das
sieht doch freundlich aus aber deutlich
angriff ressort
aber die fackel ist nicht warm oder so
weit geht das spiel nicht sie habe ich
mir hier fast an will und aber sagt sie
haben machen sie so zünden sie diamanten
haben
ich dachte wir müssen uns gegen sie soll
mich nicht anfangen
ich dachte wir müssen diamanten finden
oder so sie haben ja auch instagram ein
live chat auf einen kaffee mit katia
haben sie eigentlich angst um ihre daten
was facebook und co angeht oder ist das
eher zweitrangig wenn man mal vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet wurde das
was es an datensammelei gibt es
natürlich ein riesen problem solche
angst ist nicht der richtige begriff
dafür aber politisch treibt mich das
stark um und ich habe zusammen mit
vitalisierung expertinnen von uns
manchmal gemeinsam hingesetzt und
überlegt was kann man tun um wirklich
diese enorme macht den enormen einfluss
dieser dieser paar in großen firmen wie
facebook und google um den
einzuschränken so viel zeit haben wir
nicht mehr
wir sind wieder glühwürmchen über ihn zu
wissen wer hier vielleicht müssen wir
cleverer menschen fangen
ich stehe jetzt einfach mal hier drauf
das hier ist das so ein stein was ist
wenn ich anfangs habe ich denke müssen
jetzt die krisen
wir haben es geschafft ja da ist doch
den wir machen
wir haben ihr ziel erreicht ist das eine
neue erfahrung für eine linke jedes
erreichte ziele seine zwischenetappe wo
man sich das nächste ziel freut
glühwürmchen
aber es ist jetzt nicht so dass wir zum
geist aus der flasche geholt haben oder
ich weiß es nicht vielleicht kommen wir
auch nie wieder hier raus ist es wäre
okay für mich weil ich jetzt echt schön
so wie jetzt können wir glaube ich die
brille abziehen
wie hat es ihnen gefallen publica
wahnsinn charles taze nächste level ist
das nächste level
wir sind die einzige partei chef
tatsächlich die unserer einladung
gefolgt sich bei diesen spielen sind sie
glücklicher als jahrmarkt oder haben sie
einfach weniger zu tun ich glaube
einfach dass schlecht gehe ich ein
bisschen abenteuerlustig
vielen dank kipping und da haben wir
dann doch noch eine gemeinsamkeit mit
dem sozialismus
wir sind am ende
[Musik]
ich suche wurde der arrogante und
weitere videos